I really came up reading comics in the
maladies there was a trend just
transition in comics where they went
from being inspired by novels to being
inspired by movies where they stop being
so caption heavy and describing the
things to you all they're showing it to
you and more about just showing it to
you and that kind of led to the
explosion of comments now being so
interchangeable with them and I'm doing
some work in television and film right
now and it's it's a lot of fun to get to
play around in that world entertainment
is all one thing you know it doesn't all
just have to be comics and movies and TV
it's all just telling stories and that's
what i like to do so I embrace it all
the walking dead is a horror comic
series the zombie movie that never ends
essentially i'm on a train and i'm
laying track as far ahead as i can but i
like to keep it loose so that i can
change things as I come up with ideas
most jambe movies about a group of
characters dealing with extenuating
circumstances and extreme condition
until the length of the movie runs out
and then they hop in a helicopter that
goes off watching those movies I always
thought well the interesting part is
what do they do next and so that's what
I'm doing in a way that I don't think
anyone's ever really done it before it's
like the Simpsons only it's a zombie
comic it goes on year after year after
year